hi my name is mo jalan ambassador movie
at the united states that i was just a
panelist at the session on latin
american and asian relations American
sessions there was clear to recommission
that this is the time for stronger latin
american and asian relational start rape
is doubling the last five years foreign
investments are rising rapidly and the
Economic Cooperation inter-regional is
also rising think they're being healthy
and strong Latin American and a
generations would just well be the key
to the reform of sustaining best balance
and it was a global growth that we were
looking for from Asia alone is not
enough from Latin America alone is not
enough the two widgets need to connect
and enhanced economic collaborations to
contain their sustainable and not as
global economy and what we need to do
more as we discuss in the session was
how to reduce the metro barrier asian
business and latin business think that
he checks the formal mathematics too far
even though the geographical presence in
its part the mental barrier in the
reducer winterization business latin
america is a smart united states yet
which we go up with so it's just matter
of perception and is one of things that
need to do more to reduce mental barrier
and also to get the business communities
on what time to discover more offline
charm from malaysia and azalea of mexico
gimli popular among the prophets and
loved us back young latin american
products that can be sports the Twinkie